[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using probably
for about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt wolbers and I tend to
do on-demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton and
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way incentivize me
but they really 100% hit the nail on the
head I was very very impressed with how
motivating it was
and it worked tremendously to keep me
pushing which quite honestly takes a
fair amount I can get quite lazy
particularly with anything that edges on
endurance which is kind of more than
five reps of anything for me so check it
out
discover this cutting edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that's o-n-e peloton PE l oto and
calm and enter the code Tim all caps at
checkout and get $100 off of accessories
with your policy one bike purchase so
get a great workout at home anytime you
want check it out go to one peloton calm
and use the code Tim to get started this
episode is brought to you by LegalZoom
which more than 2 million Americans have
used to help start their businesses pass
guests even such as well WordPress lead
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used LegalZoom to help with
their business needs specifically in his
case to form his company but LegalZoom
isn't just for launching your business
their services include everything from
helping you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NDA's
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get all a cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where does my job each and every episode
to deconstruct a world-class performer
from any number of different domains
business sports entertainment military
and so on and today's guest who will
perhaps debate that he himself is
world-class but I'll not allow it is
Toby littke who is the founder and chief
executive officer of Shopify CEO that is
of shop fire 2004 toby began building
software launch an online snowboard
store called snow devil it quickly
became obvious that the software was
more valuable than the snowboards so
Toby and his founding team launched the
Shopify platform in 2006 he has served
as CEO since 2008 at the company
headquarters in the metropolitan
epicenter of tech Ottawa Canada it's a
fantastic place I've spent time there
beaver tails also incredible toby is an
is an active advocate for computer
literacy and education and serves as a
board member of canada learning code all
caps
CLC canada learning code and
organization working to give all
Canadians access to digital skills in
2014 Toby was named The Globe and Mail's
CEO of the year he served as chair of
the digital industries table and
advisory board commissioned by the
federal government to provide
recommendations on how to turn Canada
into a digital leader and that report
was published that is of the table in
September 2018 Toby
welcome to the show thanks so much for
having me and I feel like this is a long
time coming we go we go way way back and
we'll get to that but I thought we could
start with your penchant related to
optimization so I want to do a quick
fact check here so this is something I
came across in the New York Times it
doesn't surprise me but here's how it
goes I also have a weird obsession with
optimizing things this is supposedly a
quote of yours even when I was walking
to elementary school I counted the
number of steps on different routes so I
could figure out which one was shortest
and I'll just I'll just finish this up
so dot dot dot I'll just connect some
things if I had to do something once
that's fine if I had to do it twice I'm
kind of annoyed and if I had to do it
three times I'm going to try to automate
it did you count steps it's one of our
situations you know like III think I was
together with my mom my sister and my
sister was complaining about me trying
to optimize something I think we were
talking about going for a walk and I'm
like well you know if if a place we are
starting from is the same as a
destination right and we just not go and
my mom immediately said you realize you
did this from venue where like four
hours um and told me the story and it's
kind of sort of unfortunately probably
tells people way too much about me so I
don't know why this made it into the New
York Times I'm actually kind of unhappy
right now but here we are and here we
are and the the optimization or the
looking for efficiency is that something
that you're you're either of your
parents has or did that seem to kind of
come out of left field I think I don't
know it's probably one of us unexplained
kind of quirks which and that after
probably many many years where it's
annoying everyone around me suddenly
starts becoming useful after you know
because you know as a especially as a
programmer it's it's been wonderful all
right it's you know I love these old
machines where you know can understand
every chip that's in the Machine you can
kind of figure out what's what try to
you know make a videogame in 90s was
really really hard and so those were
kind of things which really really
attracted me mm-hmm and just to give
people a snapshot of where things are
now and we're gonna certainly continue
with this retrospective rewinding the
clock but how big is is shopify at the
moment yeah what are some of the numbers
so yeah as I said Shopify started in
2000 2004 and became sort of released in
2006 which again that's almost like a
hundred Internet years ago where that's
it so it's been a long time and the
company now is a public company it's
about four and a half thousand people
work at Shopify we have officers and
largely across Canada but also in you
know Berlin and you know Australia and
so on and all sorts of other places we
have about I don't know a new newest
efficient numbers I think it's called
more than 700,000 customers and are all
around with word hundred seventy five
countries and so on so on so on it's
it's it's become this by almost any
metric fantastic success I was
mentioning when we were having launched
before this that I was unpacking some
boxes that I'd not yet unpacked from my
move from San Francisco to Austin and I
found the the coin from the initial
public offering and it really made me
smile because I remember when we first
met
Shopify had what would you say fifteen
fifteen people and that was that was was
that 2008 or 2009 a that's 2008 and
could you could you tell what you
remember of of that first meeting where
did where did we first meet we did we
met at a conference called rubyconf
ready we might have been raised Kornfeil
Scott rates gone that sounds right rails
Ruby and rails being the technology
Shopify has been programmed in and you
were invited as a keynote speaker I
think you did an interview with David
that's right
and with Hanna Mayer Hanson exactly so I
think we talked in the green room it's
like hey I love everything about your
book but the worst part about it is you
keep talking about using Yahoo stores
for your business and you just really
should have used Shopify and you know
what can I do to convince you of I
wasn't that direct I was probably really
shy but the the timing was perfect also
because I was in the process of doing
the final editing for the revised
edition of the of the 4-hour workweek
and I had been pulling my readers
through social media and the blog and so
on
which had at that time you
the blog already at that point had
millions of readers and asking for
suggestions for updates for the tools
and resources and Shopify was the most
consistent recommendation for e-commerce
platform and then I go to this this
conference we meet in the speaker's room
effectively you have let's say 15 or so
employees and that was the beginning of
our exchanges and then collaboration
which which we'll get into but it on one
hand seems like a previous lifetime and
on another hand just does not seem that
long ago and I have to say for people
who perhaps wonder this it does money
change people I I have to say it's been
so I didn't expect you to change and you
didn't and it's it's really refreshing I
don't know if I've said this publicly
but Shopify is one of those companies
where everyone I've ever been involved
with has been just such a genuinely good
person it's it's an example of when the
good guys have have won in a way and
it's it's it just makes me so happy that
you guys have had the outcomes that
you've had so thank you so much yeah
yeah I just want to start there it's
it's really just it gives me so much joy
to think about and let's get back to
your odd behavior as a kid it's this is
from a separate piece and this isn't
gonna be all quotes but some of these
are just so fantastic I can't I can't
not mentions is from Globe and Mail and
this this I think speaks to a superpower
of yours that may have caused problems
in the beginning and I recall reading a
quote and I'm going to butcher it but
Francis Ford Coppola the director
incredible legendary filmmaker had said
you know you receive Lifetime
Achievement Awards for the things that
would have gotten you fired in the
beginning fantastic yeah here's the
quote and this is the writer from an
early age Luca had what he calls a Thor
problems in schools in Koblenz Germany
he preferred to deconstruct the
questions teachers gave him rather than
deliver the expected answers and I was
like yep that sounds right
he took shortcuts determining the
minimum number of hours he needed to
spend in a particular class and still
pass that he could spend most of his
time with his computer one of the
patterns that I have observed with you
over the years that I think is so so
valuable and so simultaneously important
but undervalued or under discussed is
not just asking the question in front of
you but dissecting it to determine if
it's the right question so could you
elaborate a bit on that or think of any
examples that they could serve as a
launching off point or even maybe start
with why you do this yeah um wow this is
already going the interesting places
isn't yes like okay we are talking about
my authority problem and my obsession
with optimization so where do we go from
here I here's here's one thing which is
here's what the authority problem thing
has morphed into and I think this is
this is exactly the sort of pivot point
from which event from problematic to
excuse for and that is I have a serious
problem just of accepting auto Toxie
like the the here's how things are done
just kind of it doesn't that doesn't
grab me in any particular way and so
what I've so determined for myself is
what like I really want to understand
the situation and the various pressures
acting on the situation that I'm Adam
betta might get myself into so you were
taking us back with your with a little
coin that you found it's just one of us
art effects the New York Stock Exchange
gives you when you take a company public
and and so we got the two of us together
before that date when you're actually
ringing the bell you at least
traditionally like companies like
Spotify and slack are now we're doing
the Dowd listing which i think is really
really healthy for that particular
illness
but before that event you work with
bankers you build this prospectus and
then what you and when you go on a road
show and all these kind of things you
spend a grueling like talk about I don't
want to do a thing to trans to us I like
three times I had to give the same
presentation a hundred and three times
in eight days
it's absolutely there's a complete Hayes
Toby's version of hell it was my version
of which is funny because like my
business partner Holly is like the
opposite of me and loved it like so it's
good to have these people around who can
decide there's a Harley Harley probably
the person I've heard most described as
a force of nature yeah that phrase blood
till Harley exactly which I'm decidedly
not and so this is a highly loved it I
wanted to automated all the way through
but just I'm technics back there because
I think this it's a good example of this
kind of thinking one thing I did they
really in the process of actually taking
a company public was to not just
understand like how could shop if I
become like a good public company but
there was sort of obvious agency problem
that exists on the investment banker
side right and so I spent a good couple
months talking to people figuring out
what kind of things happen in the
performance review of investment bankers
like how do they make their money how do
they make their bonuses how do they you
know how do how do they string together
career what's good what's bad you know
if they get a lot of these kind of fees
is that good for them or is that neutral
if they you know so because this is this
is the I would like to come to a
conclusion like an often this is the
same conclusion that auto Toxie would
have just sent me to myself because I I
want I want to say okay I'm gonna do
these following things because I I from
first principle argued that this is the
right thing to do and I think this
morphman not actually leads to very
interesting
in sites where you can say okay because
I understand what's at play here
I can disagree with someone's suggestion
and I can maybe improve something
slightly and I think you know in an
interesting way
Shopify is a very long exercise in doing
this over and over and over again rather
than saying okay well the internet needs
online stores we have super important
entrepreneurship is one of the biggest
economic opportunity online retailers
one of the biggest entrepreneurial
opportunities of our lifetime it's like
one point nine trillion dollar industry
now it's gonna be four trillion soon
online stores need to be something that
people can create okay cool
but do people really care about online
stores I can't care what selling right
they care about becoming successful
entrepreneurs may become of they care
about reaching for independence and and
the success of like of that so that so
which pretty quickly sent us into a
direction saying okay about the do go
online store thing but let's actually
build with software that actually
supports people in the activity of
reaching for independence and and
because of as it became something else
and then success came forward with this
this is also in a way connect some dots
from earlier today when we were chatting
about a mutual friend Seth Godin yeah
and Seth and I not too long ago had this
conversation where he give the example
of which was borrowed from an example he
had read but he elaborated on it which
was semen no one wants a quarter inch
drill bit they want a quarter inch hole
and it's like no but they don't really
want a corners hole they want a shelf do
then they don't really want a shelf they
want a place to put their books and so
on and so forth yeah so you don't sort
of mistake the current characteristics
of a temporary solution as the ultimate
objective because the vote has sort of
sorted itself into solutions based on a
vote that's long gone in a way like why
I mean just looking back at my industry
like why was there a online store
industry and a point-of-sale system
industry and all these eBay
our seller two words like each of those
instances someone has a product want to
sell it through whatever channel like do
you do you want to go to like free four
or five different vendors to get
software to participate in all these
channels no you just want to do it right
and so I think it's it's it's really
worth going for life and just saying I'm
gonna hold on a second like what are
people actually trying to accomplish
what is the actual problem here I think
the most impressive story along those
lines that I've ever sort of come across
this you familiar with Malcolm McLean
story around the invention of a shipping
container I am NOT but I've had a book
about shipping containers recommended to
me multiple times probably the box yeah
what was the name the person's name his
name was mecca mclean he's he's one of
us
entrepreneurs who would absolutely be on
your podcast if he would be alive right
now
right because spent the first money out
of college on buying a truck started a
trucking company and tried to get things
shipped across the country or even to
europe and realized like you can make
the most efficient trucking system or
the the trained guys have the most
efficient trains and the boat guys have
ships all over the world but getting
something through multiple stations is
impossible like you have to unload
everything laden next so he ended up
just buying a bunch of tankers from a US
Navy which had surplus tankers at the
end of World War two and just this came
up with this idea of putting a shipping
container together which you can put
things in a factory in Maine and then
bring and strip them all the way to
build in and the moment he did that but
the cost of sending like a unit of good
then from I think six dollars to 16
cents it's incredible we all live in
their homes but because the shipping
container has been hugely influential in
history it's like a lot of people talk
about free trade agreements and
globalization in reality it's
globalization happens for moments
shipping container opens in a country
and it's a fascinating until like Rafa
underexpose story but what's so cool
about this is the reason why he put us
off is
because again the the Vanderbilts and
the train guys really loved their trains
and and the board guys loved loads and
he was the only person who just cared
about moving things he wanted to solve
the problem of moving things in the wood
and then you come to better solutions
and we need more of that kind of thing
yeah the the versatility I don't to get
to take an off track but the shipping
container when I was he does the
brilliance of the modular design and
yeah the ability to take a single
container and move it across different
means of transport is an endlessly
fascinating topic and a lot of folks
also don't realize the sort of genius of
the design of shipping containers and
the considerations of the dimensions and
the ability to cool or control
temperature then the entire after market
use of shipping containers also just how
I came into it I kind of backed into it
looking at different types of design and
construction that book was called the
box yes the box so since since we're
talking about it might as well might as
well just hit on on something I was
going to ask that any anyway which is
which is books say you're of a I would
say a voracious but very selective
consumer of information and there's a
lot of garbage out there
you mentioned the box there's another
book and I think it might have been in
Harley's office where I first saw it at
Shopify but high output management
mmm-hmm by Andy Grove that's one of my
best books ever one of the best books
ever so I want to and then another one
that I've listed here is drive by Daniel
pink I'm not sure if we if you want to
comment on that but could you mention a
few books that you have found
particularly helpful and maybe start
with high output management and why that
is a good book so so I attacked you back
in sort of two early days I started at
Shopify as you know hey I only want to
do technology a I'm programmer by trade
right so this is my word and I wanted to
treat business as a black box for first
couple of years and then for various
reasons have a sort of thrust into also
having to take over the business side of
Shopify around that time actually we met
and I did a poll of people I knew for
two books to read because I wasn't
business folks exactly so because up
until this point I was knee-deep and
Martin Fowler and Ken back and all these
kind of luminaries of a programming book
but I had no idea about business and so
the two books I read which is funny
because it tells you how good that
selection process was because I still
think was a problem they would rank in
the top five books I've ever read and I
had a completely wrong view about how
good business books were afterwards them
where a high-output management by Andy
Grove and influenced by eldini Kathy
knee exactly so that was a very
fortuitous to first books to read and he
got off to a good start yeah so so
Andy's pork is unapologetically almost a
how-to meant a manual that kind of just
deconstructs the world of business into
its into first principles
it's like here's what matters here's how
to think about it no one needs a degree
this there's a little bit of
circumstantial contextual understanding
but you just have to have but basically
it basically at the end of the day
making a business is an engineering
exercise and it's just brilliant for me
because that's like that actually
connected that MIT made the whole thing
about becoming a CEO significantly less
scary to me because you know engineering
I understand and then inference was just
the most mind-bending book you can
imagine because it's essentially told
you all the ways humans are flawed and
influential and how yes computers are
predictable and you can deal with it but
then once once you make things for
people you need to go into storytelling
and you know framing matters but you're
also news to me I spent my teens with
computers and other people
so I I came as a like my wife would you
know would dine out on this topic and
just probably make fun of me for hours
but like she always says I mean I am an
immigrant to her human condition
supposed to send me off to a good start
I just want to save oh um voracious
reader ferocious voracious variations
that's how you say that like I'm
Dyslexic I actually read very slowly I I
sort of overcome dyslexia but like I I
read books very slowly I think I it's
actually a bondage frankly I have very
high recollection but because of this I
have to be very selective on only books
I read so I'm not one of us a hundred
books a year kind of people how do you
how do you choose books now
or maybe we is an example Ike the box
why did that come on your writer how did
that make the cut the box came because I
I usually have a topic and then just
dive right like III dive into it like
the in this play in this case I was like
hey I'm running Shopify Shopify causes
you know billions like tens of billions
of dollars of Commerce activity and most
of us is going to go through a logistics
network but I don't understand and I
feel my job as a CEO is have to have the
most full stack understanding of every
component and that that's at all related
which is frankly given that via book
booking here in world trade is almost
the entire human condition so it's an
endless source of interesting deep dives
into topics but in this case I was more
about with logistics would like it's a
fascinating world because it's been
built for millennia and you know like
the the the Silk Road has still impact
on the way the world economy works today
and then stitching these things together
absolutely fascinating but just even in
verse sort of first okay let me let me
let me start digging it became pretty
clear that that there was a history
before was shipping container and a
history after a shipping container and
if
these situations and there's a specific
date where everything changes like mint
Astro evolution or something another
example of that what I tend to like
doing is I like to find the players like
the people who had a lot of input on
this kind of thing or just at least we
had the front row seat and then read
their biographies because they don't
tend to try to sell you anything other
than that this person played an
important role but they tend to be the
most critical of witnesses to actually
buy outside events without so much bias
towards convincing you about it was good
or bad and so in this particular case it
was very easy there was actually a
perfectly good book about exactly the
guy who came up with it and so I've been
posing obvious choice what other
actually before we get to subjects in
more books because this this may bridge
over to something that I did not know I
feel like I should have known this and
it makes perfect sense but I did not
know this so this this is I suppose one
of your problem domains we can discuss
what that means when you became CEO and
I have a question about that also but
this this is this is quote from a media
piece and I could try to paraphrase it
but it take a lot longer so you as part
of his here's the piece as part of his
self-directed crash course he decided to
fly to Silicon Valley now I'm gonna
pause here for a second because people
listening might think of course you go
to Silicon Valley to learn from
fantastic entrepreneurs and so on but
it's it takes a different turn here
which i think is really indicative of
how you're thinking how you apply very
structured thinking to things back to
the piece he set up meetings with
venture capitalists and listen to their
questions about shop finds attrition
rates and conversion rates and funnel in
parentheses the various means by which
company attracts the attention and skews
a commitment of new customers it's a
long way to say that he had no idea what
they were talking about but he wrote
down the terms so then he went back to
the hostel he was staying and looked
that also tells you something hostile he
was staying in and looked at everything
on Wikipedia he would then read up on
how to calculate contribution margin
ratio and the amount by which sales
exceed variable production cost then go
to Shopify's database
the numbers Oh he'd think that's an
interesting way to look at the business
then at the next meeting he was able to
answer one more question this is this is
a really clever way to go about thank
you getting a fixed about time I mean
you're learning by observing the
questions and defining the terms see
this is why I love podcasts at my
favorite thing in the world it's like I
books are like definitely ranked up
there but it's just one thing which is
better which is being a flying a wall
and two experts talk amongst each other
right which is one of those situations
that was almost impossible to line up as
an outsider and now suddenly is
completely democratized for a wonderful
invention of podcasting but back then
and before that I sometimes managed to
do it via finding a chatroom or forum
where people the experts talked amongst
each other but it's something I was
always seeking in this case so then when
I was trying to learn about some
technology like some some esoteric 3d
rendering algorithms but I was found
interesting I I used to try to find like
where people talk about optimizing these
things and then I I just don't
understand anything that they're talking
about but then I chip away at it and I
would come into the knowledge and so I
tried to replicate this and and and and
and talking to venture capitalists ended
up being sort of a way I figured out how
to potentially do it because again I had
no background in business I had no idea
how this all looked I had and I had to
do it fast because Toph was an edge
however I wasn't doing it well right
like it was very very tough to keep the
company alive so let's let's it this is
maybe a good opportunity to explain to
people why why you took over as CEO just
the circumstances but the circumstance
was simple and probably a fairly common
it's I I had a co-founder first node
ever which was no BOTS door and we did
the like I did to the technology he did
I ran the store and did a million other
things like find us an office at some
point and so on but as the company
pivoted much
watch being a software company and
started growing and for crying were more
people at some point like it was a
different situation and so he sort of
came to me and said decided that he
wanted to transition out and that really
you know I mean well was very surprising
because again I really wanted to treat
business as a black box I have fought
business just I mean it was a program a
people you don't like business it sounds
good yeah that's I was gonna send
reading it as a black box is a very
diplomat diplomatic way to say it as a
programmer yeah yeah I just didn't want
to like become the point he had postman
tipper come back right so I so this is
iteration it is just a rose and I I
actually looked for a CEO for a long
time I I met with a lot of people who
got came recommended as potential see
your replacements and it was one of my
early investors know the the microphone
investor friendly who at some point took
me aside and said Toby you will never
find anyone who kept the key about
Shopify as much as you do
and so you should just give this a go
and that was pretty scary advice but I
like the challenge I I mean why do we
entrepreneurs do this thing
it's like why do we even build companies
it's it's such a silly idea right like
think about how irrational is this this
is not my fault but like someone said
like you you spend a hundred hours a
week
avoiding working forty hours a week for
someone else it kind of makes no sense
right like and and very especially
tactic that's such a minor chance of
actually getting any kind of returns on
it and so you don't do this for for for
at least suddenly well I can't I can
only speak for myself I certainly did
not do this for monetary reasons reason
why I did it is because I thought it
sounded amazing not having to answer to
anyone you know back to our four key
problems and
I wanted to make my own sort of
technology decisions these kind of
things and I want to see what I can do
I I want to change myself and I said
like this is the right time my life I
was 24 when I started this is the right
time of my life to give us a go I will
learn alt on like there's no way this
could be a failure on a personal level
other than in the way about you know
maybe people lose money on me but real
failure was a very real thing but I knew
I would learn a lot and so that I
reconnected at first and said ok this is
another challenge to become the business
side of a business as well and I'm going
to learn a lot again and so I traveled
to a second Valley it's funny because I
found this hostel close to Center Road
they're all VC Spielberg man and I
bought a bike on Craigslist and and and
it spiked to all these things I may even
see like if you look at Center Road it's
not made for bikes it's not and biking
interface like leeming palaces of
capitalism I just have to imagine
they're like yeah some guys coming in
from Ottawa Canada how do I Canada like
wait is that him on the bike this is
exactly the situation you just you're
just adding to the picture that that's
that's perfectly accurate and yeah so I
talked with him I learned a lot I I
thought they found this somehow I was
endearing in some way because I'd
actually did keep contact with a lot of
them they didn't actually run me out of
the offices which is also speaks to
second valley you know it's some a it's
amazing place where you can take
meetings with people who will give you
ready bit time and advice and a puzzled
it out right like I figured it out it
turns out I needed to learn a lot about
certain terms and so on but yeah figure
it out and I'd love to talk for well I
first took first an observation which is
how much
how much fun it was for me and also
instructive to meet you when I met you
right that's really that is quite a
transitionary period in which to meet
Toby so it's it's been really really
fantastic to watch as things have
evolved over time that now that said
part of what makes it interesting is the
good decisions but also the challenges
and maybe some of the bad decisions can
you talk to in any order you like some
of the some of the good decisions that
you made and some of the bad decisions
that you made when after taking on the
role of CEO yeah I would be good to have
some sort of obvious examples here but I
mean it's almost every good decision
starts somehow bad first right it's they
happen like we've made almost every
mistake in the book but we also the kind
of company that wants to in a way you
know like we it's been so important to
me to build a company various kind of it
is unafraid of experimentation and and
and where failure like within Shopify we
don't even be sort of I think we
succeeded in this we eliminated the talk
of a term failure like be renamed we
call it the successful discovery of
something that did not work because I
think it really changes people's
disposition to it so what did we do
wrong like if he did I well I was just
gonna say I mean if I don't want to
interrupt your answer but if I think
that what you just said could also take
us in a pretty interesting direction
right if you if you want to buy some
time to think about the not failures
failures in quotation marks yes I say
there are a number of things that seem
paradoxical that I don't think our
paradoxical in practice maybe they are
but I want you to comment on them and I
just have to find the the right quote
here well I'll give you I'll give you
the first part so the first part is a
quote of yours I believe
your
here needs to make an impact like a
crater right so it's not just good work
it's not excellent
it's massive cosmic impact it needs to
be visible from outer space and so
people you people are encouraged to take
risks yes
now at the same time another quote here
okay
Toby Shannon right all right sue so this
is on you know it's going this is on
receiving feedback from Toby be prepared
to be crushed Shopify's vice president
of reputation and if you can't be
crushed you don't make it on the
executive team you need fix kin it's not
that it's not that Toby shouts or treats
people meanly he's simply direct
unfiltered when he looks at the fruits
of someone's labor he says what he
thinks even if what he thinks is this is
[ __ ] okay so how do you how do you
combine these two things successfully
the things I love about you is that it
is you get you don't get the
sugar-coated kid-glove version of Toby's
thought you get Toby's thought so how do
you encourage risks when the the
feedback you receive at the end might be
that was total [ __ ] you can do better
yeah now I I want to register that that
quote came up in 2015 and you know since
then I have learned I might vet I should
translate something like this [ __ ] into
is this really the best way we can do
this but it's I mean it's the same thing
in a different form really yeah here's
something I've always like a Wikipedia
right like there's a I hope I get the
name right there's a a specific editor
from the early days of Wikipedia who I
think was called he had to handle that
Cronk oh and he declared something
called cron cross rules which said that
he wanted everyone to edit his pages
just to make them better and he didn't
want people to apologize for it and or
try to
like give him credit or something he
said I'm gonna take a hundred percent
responsibility for my own mental state
like I like you cannot make me unhappy
by just giving me feedback in some way
so just give me a real feedback without
all that like [ __ ] sandwich Iran I love
that I I just I would like to run my
team on chromecast rules because I think
it's just there's this so much time
spent like first you have to talk about
whoever and then you know I need to say
yes whether exactly it's you to find
something and then ideally address some
they productive character traits then
talk about the thing you want to talk
about and then figure out some way of
afterwards talking about something
highly positive against of it you know
that's that's a sort of standard formula
and I can do it
but I don't think that the highest
performing teams in the world should
spend time doing this to each other I
think there's a level of progression
that comes if you're part of one of the
teams and again like via whatever bigger
technology companies in the world
certainly I think the fastest-growing
sales company on the market and so you
know it's not like I want to compare too
much to sports because Sports is its
sports or sports but this is like a big
game right like we need to be very good
at what we're doing otherwise you cannot
build Shopify and so I think these
things are in the way and so yes I want
people to be impact for like again if a
hard object collides with a soft object
and suddenly like there's no crater to
prove it right and so I want people to
take the sort of mental state in their
own hands and just say okay I'm gonna
learn how to you know be intrinsically
reminded that I'm good at what I'm doing
and not have to rely on other people
constantly telling me do you help
just shop if I have any type of training
or resources or cultural rules that are
explicit that help to facilitate that
type of awareness because there are
people who
meditate for ten years with that
objective and never quite get there and
you can hire the town you can already
find the people like you could go out
and you could hire Jacko willing right -
yeah run your HR and you would give them
all a copy of extreme no ownership guy
here we go
but then there are people who come in
who might be exceptional performers yeah
but very sensitive in some way I've run
into that quite a bit
yeah what do you do in a situation like
that or what are the things that you do
or that Shopify does to help people take
that ownership of their internal state
because this is hugely important yeah
it's hugely important so the one thing
it's so neat about Shopify is again
let's get a little bit back to this
Ottawa Canada thing I had clearly as you
said this is off the beaten track of the
startup word ended up being an
phenomenally good place to build a
world-class company but for reasons that
we're also not clear to me even a
started where a couple of things that
happen when you're not in second Valley
right or like latina not let's call it a
primary like company creation city
tenure gets longer like if I hire
someone through this very integrated
hiring process but they have a sort of
an understanding that it's the chance of
us still working together in ten years
is actually really high right I mean
it's a commitment from both sides and of
the company to be worth working for for
ten years that's what I work on day in
day out but because of that we can have
a very different relationship than in a
place where they expected ten years 18
months in an 18-month place I really
have to kind of access every good idea
and and and and the productive power of
let's say an engineer so immediately if
they need to be productive and they need
to be really pampered in some cases to
even keep them for 18 months because you
have Facebook Google and the name five
other companies who were all pea
Chane the same employees at those five
companies yeah
via headhunters yeah and so so in a
place like this ends up for better or
for worse in a world where people don't
actually go having careers at companies
anymore because the way to have a career
is actually jumping between companies
you use so your new position is always
slightly slightly higher and so well our
cities aren't like that the V assume
that we have this long chain and 10-year
relationships and therefore Shopify and
can invest in the people who are part of
Shopify in a completely different way so
we have a big amount of we've probably
hired all business coaches in Canada and
Britain and Beyond at this point to be
full-time employees of Shopify because
we investing so much in the people we we
hire people on future high potential and
then try to get them there as fast as
possible because that actually works for
us and for for networks for people and
works for Shopify fantastically well and
so we have a lot of these opportunities
because of that to make some slight
edits to the normal sake right like so
feedback is a gift it's a it's not a
simple sentence but really it's not the
way most people think about feedback
right and your back is a gift feedback
is a gift because it is it clearly is
it's not the Sun meant to hurt it's it's
meant to move things forward or I'd like
to demystify something for you I want I
want Frank feedback from everyone and I
I get it although funny enough I don't
know if you know like you me you might
have a thought about this I tend to get
it from the Germans at Shopify so there
might be a cultural component here too
so but yeah so this like did he said
call it crush of egos or get your ego
crushed Oh sounds good yes be prepared
to be crushed you can't be crushed you
don't make it on the executive team yeah
I would say that might be a little em'ly
or learn learn how not to feel crushed
yes so so I mean this is the executive
team which is directly MIT and I love
the people who have the highest
requirements off and
book together for longest so I think I
don't think it's like this everywhere
and Shopify how does are there
particular mmm particulars particular
types of training exercises that are
used within Shopify to help people take
ownership of their internal state or to
view feedback as a gift that people
listening might be able to use or
explore think about in some way um if
the company is the via very I like
different companies have different sort
of personality traits testing and kind
of things that they like Shopify is very
partial to a system called Enneagram and
you go I just had my first Enneagram
typing last week and you are a 8i appear
to be a loyal skeptic six oh wow
interesting yeah there you go yeah we
could we could get into it this is a
well Benny Graham has been in this book
very very well for us
um like you know our internal system you
can actually see the Enneagram of
everyone else and then it tells you like
how like what nuances that means for how
to work together for instance so that's
one but the other thing I think why
personality tests are interesting is
they it doesn't matter which one it is
after you kind of do one it already kind
of teaches you like hey wait a second
the way I'm wired is different from when
people around me yeah and I think this
is so fruitful offer discovery
especially early in your career right
because again a lot of the people we
hire like average age of Shopify's 30 29
I think so we get to people very early
in their career and because what the
thing that we want to accomplish and
this is really the goal of all of
internal programs is we want to take
people from a find out what parts of
what kind of areas they have a fixed
mindset on and try to get people to
become to acquire growth mindset alright
just think of air intelligence as
something that can be trained think of
their skill as a pro c'mon
as something static and when someone
comes and tells you but there's
something you could have done better
that's not someone finding out that
you're not as good as you thought that's
actually a teacher appearing right and
once people acquire this growth mindset
on at least a number of different trades
usually they arrive to like they they
make it very very far and they can have
his like 10 years of a career in in one
year on the on the wall clock and it's
it's it's a it's a wonderful kind of
thing when the event happens how would
you suggest the people acquire a growth
mindset because there are books I don't
know if Grit I haven't read Angela
Duckworth is book great it's been
recommended a number of times but there
are a number of books that talk about
the importance of growth fostering
growth versus fixed mindset in child
yeah
rearing and you shouldn't say your
you're so smart you should say you
worked really hard and did a good job
and so far yeah because inevitably if
they have what's perceived to be a
failure or make mistakes
it's then not indicative of them being
stupid but rather and something related
to effort and or a chance that they can
play a part in resolving or improving
right but if we're talking about let's
just say there's there are any number of
people certainly listen to the podcast
and like you know what like I'm sure I
have a fixed mindset somewhere but I
don't you I don't I don't know if it's a
blind spot I don't know where how I
would spot it and then how do I fix it
what would your thoughts be um I think
that it's a really really good question
I wish I had a better answer I I do find
that Kara directs her original book
called mindset is probably still the
best source this dwe ck and yeah yeah I
count right yeah that was also we were
talking about Josh Waitzkin during lunch
also a book that he's quite a fan of
yeah yeah I'm a big fan of a book it's
it at least talks you through a theory
and what I've observed is even the very
very high super successful executives
will come to Shopify and what I have
worked at shop refer for a very long
time
and they end up reading the book and
they said you know what I was actually
fixed mindset on all these like these
free things and it's like it really irks
me now I it's just really funny the way
how it just awakes you're up to this to
this reality that we can all have it
it's it's not something you can over
completely overcome but it's something
that just having the awareness is really
powerful and also if you are if you have
doubt reports in a company even if that
book does nothing for you it will allow
you to be a much better lead to most
people because it's like just priming
you to a detect fixed mindset talked in
other people and pointing it out is
hugely beneficial so when I want to note
an observation that may or may not be
true but it seems to me that the
discussion of fixed and growth mindset
goes hares quite well with Enneagram
also Enneagram by the way I was
introduced to by drew of Dropbox oh yeah
and I was always skeptical and I still
am somewhat skeptical of certain aspects
of Enneagram which I think actually
means a nine pointed so there are nine
different types there's a lot of
discussion of three different books and
experts about Enneagram but like you
said as you're in your commentary about
Enneagram it's it's not necessarily the
specifics of the sort of business
acceptable horoscope that you get it's
it's the fact that you begin to look at
relating to other people and your
weaknesses and or fixed mindsets
differently right and so I found it very
useful I had my I'm going to have well
my girlfriend did her typing and I'm
going to have all of my employees do
their typing also just so they think
with an awareness about interactions
through that lens even if the exact
content may be you know 50% kind of hand
wavy yeah that makes sense
yeah because here's why we've all these
things matter I once read that I am
particularly believe in hell but
I like this definition of it hell is
meeting the best version that you could
have become at the end of your life yeah
and so I think that one of the really
really fun things about you know an
experience like an entrepreneurial
journey like the like if a company the
careers we have the books we read like
if they end up being pointed in sort of
a direction that allows us to minimize
the difference between that person via
the meat and the person we are at that
point of time I think that's time well
spent and there's some key I think
events in one's life I'd have to go
through it like at some point hopefully
you realize that the people around you
are very different that you have some
unexplained traits in you which some of
them being becoming big strengths and
some of them are weaknesses and you
double down on your strengths and you
you you try to work around your
weaknesses and by way later in life it
might actually flip which ones a switch
which is gets really weird but that's
never one of us kind of things we're
sort of awakening to a growth mindset is
is another one of us life events I think
and so these events matter because what
you're building eventually is like some
kind of path that allows you to wake up
smarter every day then if you do if
you're if you get there really really
powerful things happen suddenly you know
jumping into like a completely new job
but you have no qualification for
suddenly doesn't sound scary anymore I
mean it probably to the doors a little
bit but the challenge and the thrill of
it of like this sounds real I could fail
III I now have to I have to grow to make
this book actually become hugely
motivating and and and I think that one
of the most amazing things that anyone
can go through and you know the kid can
do in their lives is to like is is a
variation on the theme of going on a
journey doing hard things
with my friends right company building
is one of those things often travel as
another one sports are really good at
these kind of things yeah I would love
Jacko's opinion on if was like bad oh I
think even you would definitely say that
so you know variations on this theme is
what you want to prepare for I want to
come back to you something you mentioned
earlier that I think is very very
relevant here so you talked about I'm
gonna try to tie a few different things
together you talked about taking risks
and looking for opportunities for
massive impact you also talked about how
you have looked at certain opportunities
or transitions as opportunities for
learning and that you've made a lot of
mistakes but it seems to me that you've
even in some ways optimized for learning
and I just want to highlight for for
folks listening and also just to remind
myself that this is something that comes
up quite frequently with people who seem
to just step up to bat and hit home run
after home run if you really dig under
the hood that's not necessarily the case
but for instance people who are in any
number of different fields whether it's
Scott Adams in Dilbert or some of the
investors I deeply respect like Marc
Andreessen has been on the podcast they
talk about combining rather than trying
to be saying the top one percent in the
NBA which is very hard to do and a very
attribute dependent you could be say top
10% or even top 25% in things that are
rarely combined right it could be
computer science and law it could be
Warren Buffett right in value investing
and public speaking he says the the best
investment I ever made was in a Dale
Carnegie speaking course because it
magnifies everything else that you do
and so there's the combining of skill
sets that are rarely combined and as
Scott has also written about quite
extensively and I agree with that if if
and I'm paraphrasing here so I might be
mixing and matching a little but if you
optimized for learning new skills and
developing new relationships that
transcend any one given project it's
really difficult to fail completely
right and so you end up accumulating
these skills and relationships that then
help for you to combine these different
disciplines and unique ways so that that
I just want to mention because it's it's
it's tempting and debilitating to think
that you have to be the absolute best to
help 1% in X and when you when you
really look at people whether it's all
the all the various billionaires and
magazine covers or what have you that's
not necessarily the case yeah yeah I so
I could not agree more with you and I
it's interesting because I almost have
two phases to my life and with m'god
right because I really was trying to
become I don't know I don't know if I
was trying to become the best program in
the world but I certainly was making a
bit for it you know like my life was
completely revolved around writing code
understanding more of it and and then
just being very vague with it I was
going for mastery anyways and then this
situation that happened there again I
had to like cause that food and have to
go in into business and I ended up
really really liking so many aspects of
it
III really pivoted to I would like to
form from someone who is gonna try to
get I would like to understand hundred
percent of a field - I wanna as quickly
as possible understand 80 percent of
every field right and that's I like it
way better on this side and I'm
internally thankful for having realized
visits at some point because it's it is
it actually doesn't take that long - I
mean you wrote an entire book on where
so I'm obviously not trying to convince
you on this but it doesn't take long to
understand the first 80% of any number
of fields right and but of course you
can't understand 30% of every field
there's too many so you'll you'll follow
your interest pretty automatically and
and then you find out exactly this what
you just said and this is something you
know it's
it's worth looking into the Shopify
universe there the people were really
successful other people who usually have
some multiple skill sets and combine
them into some kind of new product it's
like in sort of an obvious example is
like boosted BOTS
right like he's like electrical
engineers who also like skateboarding
let's combine those two things by
putting a battery into the skateboard
and so it's really really really hard to
be the best in the world at a single
discipline but as soon as you start
overlaying like free different interests
you make Pokemon inspired jewelry or
something you can make the best pokemon
inspired jewelry in the world pretty
quickly right and so the the the speed
was that you came up with that makes me
think that that's a store on top of it
somewhere because you're in a great
position to see I mean hundreds of
thousands of these examples we see
millions of success stories and and
attempts at success stories right this
is honestly the most interesting part of
Shopify is is really the like we see
this right be like let's actually zoom
out for a second here on on my hunt of
entrepreneurship topic because it's
really dear to me but it's also at a
state that a lot of people don't really
quite appreciate entrepreneurship is in
big crisis right now it's a complete
counter narrative to what most people
most people think but right now new
company formation is that lowest points
ever been
Gen X well it sucks this started a lot
less companies a lot for your companies
when it's parents and Millennials are
lower yet so it's released
entrepreneurial generation so far and
the the numbers are going like companies
that are you know like it all numbers
are down watts per is that measured by
LLC formation and Reformation just
general companies that have all classes
in the United States over time once you
look at the graphs they all they all
just they lookin like a tank
it's especially since 2005 sort of 2006
so beginning very beginning financial
crisis suddenly fell off a cliff
so why it's bad
I'd tell me to VIII well I wish I wish I
knew it's like I know some contributing
factors like one thing is you just don't
need too many copies of everything
anymore like back in the day you
probably visited you lived in a smaller
community you visited big one you saw
hey here's like what like certain kind
of hardware store you know some kind of
you know business you've never seen
before you'd say hey I might be able to
do that back home and that's a new
company right now everything's
franchised and like centralized and it's
a lot harder to do these kind of
businesses but the same things going on
an Internet as well right my internet is
as much as it can be a democracy has
enforce it really benefits
centralization you know we have one
social networks one one search engine
and so on so it's just harder to start
businesses right and like you you you
kind of have to clock in in the top
percentile of a field or at least an
intersection of a fear of multiple
fields to even partake in
entrepreneurship and that's I think
that's not good I mean if you would give
me like hey is like two versions of a
vote choose one one in which
entrepreneurship is common and easy and
straightforward and and one vet isn't
like everything like I mean who does who
takes the one where it isn't where it
isn't easy right so how would you make
it how would you make it easier whether
in the US or maybe not a Canada specific
could be but is the is there anything
that you do to increase the number of
entrepreneurs and why is that important
is it important yeah I mean that's a
good question 50 I think should be
studied I mean like one one thing if you
look at this completely from an
economics perspective like even if you
if you think that you need to provide
employment to people you should want
like couple mega companies are not going
to employ everyone right I think
everyone in the stands with its we need
millions of 10 20 people companies as
ambe's well that's almost
everyone is employed by small businesses
if you look at the actual numbers so if
small business going away but that
that's that's definitely a force in to
evolve as a direction so how would you
do it I mean one thing is this is
actually a real problem in the United
States that's actually a problem
everywhere is licensing like it's a
crazy situation but I can get a laptop
and start fifteen billion dollar Shopify
and not need to ask no one but if I want
to become a hairdresser I need to get a
license for it right I need to go for
like like an best quote us in many
places and you can't because for all
these reasons so so that's kind of one
of those things that you have probably
people have to have a look at but the
other one is just friction like how how
difficult is that like how many things
do you have to understand to start an
online business like you put like the
supplement business many a day and
whatever all the things you had to learn
well I remember I think this was even
before that when I was taking a stab at
a few businesses all of which
self-immolated but just setting up a
merchant account I remember right back
in the day was a huge it was a complex
and hugely involved task I had to post a
thirty thousand dollar bond to get a
merchant account when I started not ever
yeah it was all the capital I had
yeah so it's wild so butBut both kind of
points of frictions are everywhere like
I mean business I don't wanna make this
mad but like the Shopify is not the
solution to this problem because it's a
much more global and bigger problem but
the retail world is one of the most
accessible parts of entrepreneurship and
that's really all shop fires like try to
take the learning curve of partaking in
like entrepreneurship building on lines
drawn on businesses and make it as flat
as possible so as many people can
succeed right that's that's what we've
been working on for the last what is it
14 years now I think this might be a
good place to chat about the build a
business competition oh yes the build a
business competition
we've been talking about just smoothing
the path or removing impediments to
entrepreneurship but you also have
incentives mm-hmm incentives are also
important what is the build a business
competition let's go back to where it's
come and come from because this is I
mean it's so relevant until two I think
two of us about suddenly to meet you
were evolved so this was 2009 so at this
point Shopify was completely running on
fumes it's like my we were completely it
just all sort of things didn't work like
you asked me earlier like things that
didn't work like the company kind of
didn't work right it wasn't like I had
the numbers and and people were selling
things and it was valuable to them but
there was no real business being built
around it and it kind of all just didn't
function my father-in-law was gracious
enough to give me a check every week for
the running payroll so so at that stage
and and and he said he would do that for
certain time and by by the end of it
we've kind of had to figure out what to
have to do at this point B but we were
talking and yeah reason why again we see
the word in a similar way you you word
for but work week but but a try to meet
in the spoke is like what you were
talking about you know just building
like a business and then actually doing
other things like this like I was seeing
people doing this on Shopify but it was
like this is an under explored form of
you know what you can do online like
people people should know about this
that this is what some people do and we
should obviously tell people that that's
what people do on Shopify and job that's
good for this kind of thing so the we
had this conversation I've ever said my
college I was actually on a boat when we
had this conversation and we're like you
know how can we overcome this built-in
fear of failure that everyone's running
around with everyone like so many people
come to me come to you and say one day
I'm gonna start my own business it's
like okay what about today you know
what's wrong
today and there's always all these kind
of reasons and I think our VOC inferi
was we just should we need to test this
by really incentivizing people and to
which I said we should like I don't know
if we should give away like a MacBook
Pro you did what you always did in our
phone calls is like like Toby first of
all that's way too nerdy and only you
care about MacBook Pros and then second
Sam if you want anyone to notice you
need to go like a hundred takes Pat's
and himself priceless unfinished
business which is probably easier to say
on your side I was by the way I was in
the Glen Park walking down I think it's
diamond Street past oh [ __ ] I remember
the exact block of we're having this
conversation yeah it's funny yeah like
this sometimes these things are just
branding you in your mind because I
think we both realized like give a visit
of egging each other on to make
something big and what ended up what we
ended up doing is said okay you're gonna
take the last hundred thousand dollars
in the bank and and and just put it up
as a competition and say whoever it's
gonna build the biggest business like
stuff like from starting now in the next
six months it's gonna just get the check
which is at this point I said this is
either going to work and then we'll make
the money come to a competition to then
give to people or companies bankrupt
anyways in which case you know I all the
other that it in some other way but they
did and I think through some contact of
you you I think you introduced me to
Laura the the New York Times ended up
talking about it because it was like
surprising it's like tiny startup in
Canada putting up something that's
beyond like every business plan
competition in terms of prize money
right I was a pretty stunning amount
yeah the biggest ever has a huge success
exactly you you were like super
confident that it would be a big success
from the beginning I thank you for this
because I
like oh my god and it's it's it's been
really it's been really awesome to watch
also a year after year as it has grown
and evolved so yeah you could give some
examples but from the beginnings right
which are we're not entirely sure I mean
a sublevel you know where the turn of
thousand is gonna come from but this is
sort of an existential bat in a way yeah
but like you said it's like there there
are other kind of inherent issues that
if we don't do it it's not clear what
the picture is going to look like and
then you flash-forward and you're doing
these build of business competitions
it's got high end reality show in the
sense that you have yeah you know the
the mansion from The Great Gatsby with
DiCaprio the people are flying all over
the world and you have Tony Robbins
coming in to mentor the finalists and so
on yes it took it took everyone to feed
you too rich to his place and Beyond
right and just it's it's been there's so
much fun to watch and you guys have done
a fantastic job of executing and it's
it's ended up coming full circle also as
I'm considering with the audience that I
have what what could I do potentially
competition-wise I you guys have taken
the ball run with it and have done this
so many years now like hey which lawyers
do turns out by the way anyone who's
thinking about doing something like this
I mean you have the prize money yeah but
then you have the putting together of a
competition yeah of this complexity
which is no joke no joke every state in
every province in Canada has completely
different laws for this you everyone
will come and ask hey is this a game of
chance here as the game of skill because
and which is actually an interesting
question before like because the
intellectually honest answer is like
chance I mean III try to never get
confused about this like show provides
an enormous leap enormously successful
but it's like 99% chance right like you
can predict all those kind of things
that you happen to transpire which which
led to success so but of course when
you're talking to lawyers your skill
absolutely yeah so we launched this in
2010 and we had an amazing win at the
end of DODOcase right of us so tell
people yeah Patrick Craig two brilliant
entrepreneurs from San Francisco who
then what Bay but they waited I think
this was around with a launch of an iPad
and so they realized these iPads need
cases just like the phones and so they
got to give up some traditional book
binders and make stuff made some sort of
some old skin looking like beautiful
like it was really just wood and
whatever mode skin is a case for iPads
and I think they gave sort of flyers to
everyone waiting in line around the
Apple store before iPad could launch so
they people wrote about it and they were
wonderful competitor a comparison of
competition they wanted and fantastic
story has a later picture of President
Obama the fist or okay is but of course
they yesterday successfully in every one
one of their marketing campaigns and
just I think actually like that goes
back to sort of a thing about really
excited me about the effects that come
from all these kind of things not just
was this an entrepreneur success story
for them and they got a $100,000 check
in rent
they also quadrupled or even beyond the
amount of professional bookbinders in
the San Francisco Bay region again like
this was something like there's an area
which had a lot of bookbinding talent
and then read for some industry and
that's not an industry anymore because
it's just not done manually anymore but
they got people out of retirement to
come back making these iPad cases and in
just a little industry exists they're
not and i think this is be so just four
stories which it's just I find so so
great this is
let's talk about we don't have to get
into all the specifics of a ton of them
but I was very curious from the first
competition to see what can people do
mm-hmm like what can people actually do
it six months right yes it's nothing I
mean but some of these people are
creating multi-million dollar businesses
from Ground Zero yes and it's it's been
really inspiring to watch and inspiring
not just because of the size but also
the variety that haven't been said one
of the things I look forward to every
year when you guys are running the build
business competitions is what patterns
will emerge because you begin to spot
and this is much like I feel like with
my audience from say the four hour work
week or the podcast but just the the the
millions of entrepreneurs who allow me
to pattern recognize because I just have
the 30,000 foot view on my audience show
me things that are coming right it's
like the Ike was William Gibson and
Neuromancer so that future is already
here it's just not evenly distributed so
you see these patterns that are sort of
this like smoke signal in the distance
and then five years later it's
everywhere and with Shopify for instance
I remember the first year that a number
of the category winners because there
are different categories right so it's
not it's not all or nothing in term at
this point in the competition there are
different would you call it industries
or product categories which which gives
more people a chance to win and it's
like wow okay so I'm making this number
up but it's like three out of the six
used to Kickstarter mm-hmm that's
interesting and looking at the different
tools and different approaches different
tactics and strategies that seem to be
used with with great efficacy each year
is also something that I have really
looked forward to and and this goes
beyond the tools into the approach I
think and this is actually where I feel
like I learned the most from from from
entrepreneurs because these are really
the best who coming like I mean
it's actually we had first-time
entrepreneurs win categories but like
they always had some kind of fantastic
insight but they're kind of adding to
this exploration about how to build
companies in this digital age so so even
the Kickstarter folks one thing the
question I always had is like what's
Kickstarter itself valuable or was it
that they had to put a certain video on
their website that wherever founders of
a company had to explain why this
product needed to exists right it seems
like such a like why does not every
product in the world have some have ever
inventor declare why they felt this
thing needed to be created like right is
why can I only get that from the people
who happen to go on Kickstarter right
yeah and most of them ended up figuring
out approaches which are really about
storytelling like what's the story I go
dude okay story is a story of every
revitalization of a craft right which
may be connected with the the the
beautiful object that came out of it was
completely imbued by this story and and
if then I was walking around with my
daughter cares like someone would talk
about it I would talk about how this was
handmade by real bookbinders because I
owned part of that story and that's
that's really a great thing the really
great thing is that things that are
powerful and work have actually not
changed in the Internet age like we've
all kind of I mean the our ancestors
over once whatever story tell us or at
least four people will listen to the
most diverse stories this is how
language developed you know like your
storytelling creatures and it's it just
is rediscovering this medium of the
medium is something that is really
really fascinating English if you if
you've looked back to the the two books
you mentioned when you're looking at
influence or you're looking at a Negros
book also not snapshot in time dependent
on the technology of right now all right
these are principles and you know I've
often thought about Kickstarter also and
and other platforms like it
as a talent assessment for some of the
basic competencies that one will need in
the company they would then subsequently
built minds like if you cannot sell your
product in a video and then marshal
resources and try to garner PR however
however you take your approach to raise
a rift in potentially nominal sum of
money for a first manufacturer I'm like
how couldn't you ever have the
confidence then that you would be able
to proceed and build something large
over an extended period of time I think
it's it's it's a it's an audition in a
sense and so then it brings up all sorts
of other questions just getting back to
the very first thing or one of the first
things I asked you about like
questioning the question it's like is it
a survivorship bias is it that there are
more people tempting things and
therefore they can kind of stress tests
and then run with the things that work
and that is why you have this higher
percentage peering in say a shop fight
build a business competition in any case
it's it's been it's been such a fun ride
and thanks for having me as part of it
well how you kind of started like you
shouldn't dump lay your your your input
on the whole thing so yeah it's and and
I wanted to also before I forget and
since I think other people listening
might find it of interest mention a book
that's kind of gonna segue over to
something that may or may not bear fruit
will see but the the book that I would
recommend alright bear with me guys this
is gonna get very Tim Ferriss ADHD for a
second but you mentioned dyslexia do you
not have any issues with real-time
review of code as you're writing it no
okay that's interesting
no one yeah okay that's just for another
time I was just like sort of
neurologically not optically that's very
interesting and just say it says is a
fascinating question but no I don't ok
alright so the he the and I just had
that come to mind because I'm gonna
recommend a book but
it's a short book by a reasonably
recently deceased Jesuit priest who's
also trained as a therapist named
Anthony de Mello the book is called
awareness and the subtitle is the perils
and opportunities of reality but it's a
collection of effectively transcribed
talks that were given by Anthony it was
recommended by a guest sense podcast
peter malukas in finance and i i decided
to pick it up because he said it every
time he reads it and he reads it more
than any other book it gives him an
extended sense of peace and I was like
that's an interesting that is not the
phrase or explanation that I would
expect so how that way to settle yeah
then I picked it up and awareness the
perils and opportunities of reality
I think a will you you you you might
just find strikes a chord it's it's a
very easy read and for me it did give me
this extended sort of afterglow effect
of inner peace for about two weeks and
I've decided that I'm probably going to
reread it less than a month after having
finished it and it is it's proven very
valuable for me even though I do have a
meditation practice to reinforce sort of
through the prefrontal cortex the value
of owning your internal state and be
choosing to be or develop the
responsiveness as opposed to reactivity
and this this this on a macro level
makes me think of comfort discomfort and
how humans relate to that something that
came up in doing research for this was
the concept of and then I maybe I may be
barking up the wrong tree here but we'll
see where it goes the next box and what
the box is not in the shipping container
sense could you talk about what what I'm
referring to
yeah it's it's attempt from a talk I
gave I was invited to like a local event
and they needed me to do a Kino
I don't tend to do these kind of things
a lot so but I kind of wanted there was
something if I just asked me to share
something and so I said well personal
growth is something that I'm you know
thinking a lot about and feel like I was
going through so I decided to like just
explain it the way I see it without
really going deep into the like current
slide guys thinking about it but and so
this is this is sort of what I explained
a you know that many a bit then you back
in high school I I remember being back
in high school and I remember that you
know there was cool kids a nun quit and
and you know we've probably been to
different sites of that kind of divide I
was I was before uncool kids like I was
the Dungeons & Dragons nerd kid so I
actually got my ass kicked up until
about sixth grade and then a growth
spurt and then I was I was just an angry
big rageful vigilante but up until sixth
grade I was definitely in the in the
nerd camp
all right so and again I don't know why
we keep talking about me as a kid
because not that interesting but it
seems to keep coming up when this is
already you want to tell you way too
much about me as a kid I at some point I
sit decide okay I want to analyze why
some kids are cool I am NOT and and and
what I came back with was the the
cookies all had Air Jordans so so I
wanted them to and of course at some
point I caught them and it totally
didn't make a difference but the reason
why this is valuable is the high school
is sort of it's it's it's a universe
it's kind of a box and it's it's hard to
get in it because it feels very
uncomfortable you don't understand that
your honor said the social network
influences and when you're trying to
kind of make sense of it all right in
your own way and and it actually becomes
reasonably comfortable then after you
sort of explain it to yourself now it's
a small box narrow and you probably your
understanding of it is wrong like
like mine was about how I could join the
queer kids right at some point hopefully
what happens is you you you find a crack
somewhere in the narrow box you're in
and you go into the outer box we have a
this box you just came from it's like a
tiny parcel in the corner like it's a
much bigger place maybe maybe college or
work life but again it feels super
uncomfortable you arrive in that new box
not understanding physics not
understanding the situation what's
expected of you it's all ambiguous you
have to reinvent every early even those
things you've figured out before are no
longer true and you notice this at sort
of an internal level and the trick is
though to at some point figure out
figure it all out and then comes a
dangerous part because it's now
comfortable again and so what you have
to do though is you have to go and find
for crack and go into the next box
around this fear suddenly all your
college life and all these kind of
things just a small box in a corner
somewhere and suddenly over it's much
bigger and you need to learn more and
understand more and so on I find I've
met luckily at various times in my life
is people who clearly occupied a much
larger box and they just sort of bent
down to me to talk to me because they
could just somehow like usurp is one
thing and and what they said back to you
was so clearly right but you could never
have understood yourself based on this
voltage point you had right and they
were usually the way how do you then
enter the larger box and so on can you
think of any are you willing to give any
examples of yeah I mean an exchange like
that I had um like it's a recurrent
thing it still happens to me to a stay I
mean I'm the specific case I was
thinking of back in the days I started I
left school after tenth grade I started
my apprenticeship as a computer
programmer which is the thing you can do
in Germany and I spent a good deal of
time on computers understood man could
do programming and so on but there was a
guy who by the name of Yogi's who was
sort of my designated mentor in this
apprenticeship program
and he was one of those people who not
just like I could ask any question he
would have a perfectly like you could
write it down what he said back you know
I was like he just everything came back
fully formed sam harris type yeah and
but then also he just created like he
was just an incredible mentor to meet
because he created this almost with
scenarios for me right like he you know
he would do my code reviews and so on
but also he would sign us up to drive to
some customer which i and him read to
writing some software for and then he
would just find an excuse for not being
able to go and just let me go myself and
i was like 17 18 years old right I just
got my travel license it's I'm just
trying to imagine having spent a lot of
time with you I had to get the 400 D
mark this was before euros is like 200
euros to buy a suit from the company I
did not have that money right going
through custom and song software now why
why did he do that he because he thought
I could do it hmm
and that pushes it like it's like he
fought he did think that I would
probably not fail and I was good enough
odds for him and like he was an uber
customer was he knew they wouldn't
likely like he couldn't pull a stunt
like this and and they would find it's
funny it's very little personal risk for
roughly and then you know like you do
this and they learned a lot and of
course my quota totally didn't work and
I had to use some satellite uplink to
get the new version and I like but I
came back and said hey in this sort of
world view box thing I was in just
yesterday it's implausible that I would
have succeeded doing this thing but I
just yesterday did so therefore I think
I'm an uncomfortable new box right now
and and I have to relook at everything I
know and we categorize everything and
and you can kind of just figured out how
to get me through a couple of one of
hours and and so I don't know if it's a
good metaphor for growth III but it's
it's a one that just sort of kind of
came to my mind then the first time I
ever supposed to sort of explain this to
people and what I like about it is that
it affirms the thing that makes it hard
to grow because it is the dangerous part
of when you feel comfortable in the box
you're in and every one of us has at the
family reunion the one uncle who decided
to not traverse in to fill the boxes way
too way too early right they figure they
have the entire world figured out and
everything makes sense to them and of
course everyone else looks at it and
says oh my god what am I talking about
right so I have a few questions about
that
this is the topic of comfort zones our
topic of great interest to me but also
it comes back to awareness as well for
instance do you know what box you are
currently in and the next box you want
to go to or is it not possible until you
have someone bend down and kind of poke
you in the forehead yeah I don't think
you can i i'm i i i know that i'm in i
mean i I know I'm always in a box
I actually am this is personal like
personally I think I I have figured out
the box I mean I'm currently not seeing
the exit which makes me uneasy we would
observe over time moment I I would say
that I understand the Box I'm in and I
haven't found the exit and the funny
thing is I've done this so many times
that I'm actually really uncomfortable
being comfortable
I really dislike not understanding where
my neck the growth comes from so I'm a
seeker right now are you comfortable
sharing what the box is that you're in
there you don't know the exit from I
mean it's sort of it's it's nothing
there's nothing terribly profound it's
sort of like it's my life right it's
like I understand how to be a public
company CEO it's just crazy sentence
that I never when 16 year old - we would
never have imagined me authoring but I I
understand the systems of Wall Street
and understand the company but I've
built I understand how to I think be the
best leader I can be for the company I
I've made a lot of progress sort of in
my personal life just sort of you know I
started working out and you know like
always kind of like just have a
meditation practice you know all these
kind of good things but you have
been recommending forever and I finally
came around to so so that's that's good
but it's comfortable in a way like I'm
seeking right now I'm trying to poke at
this eye I'm trying new things to figure
out how to come break out of it how do
you choose those things how do you
choose the things that might be the
right stress test to find that crack
usually I mean one the I mean books are
generally good like far-field books are
useful I'm really interested in sort of
in just psychology right now because
there's a lot of more interesting topics
than people think but also challenging
myself you know like I'm I'm I'm in a in
driver development program for motor
sport motor racing which is super fun
that's amazing it's it's like you know
talk about getting in a car not thinking
about anything for like two hours four
hours that's it's like yeah so you're
highly incentivized not to think about
other things yeah well exactly because
that's a real repercussions this is not
like the successful to discover
something that did not work this was a
war so you know just like like doing
things that that that is different from
from from anything else that's fit like
import things from other people's boxes
who are presumably in bigger boxes as a
way of doing it
now I I would also love your help to
clarify something no not so much for you
because I think I know the answer but
maybe for people listening and that's a
distinction I know as I'm sure you know
many many people who think that more
money more X more Y will make them happy
or content or at peace and they never
reach that moving goalposts and you and
I also I'm sure have come across its
more common Silicon Valley than the not
Ottawa perhaps but people who have tens
of millions hundreds of millions of
dollars and are absolutely miserable and
is the feeling feeling very
uncomfortable with comfort a symptom of
lack of contentment or is it something
else if that if that makes sense in my
time with you you don't you don't strike
me as like you are not one of those
miserable miserable people I've seen you
with your family I've seen you with your
friends like you surround yourself with
good people I wouldn't be like no no
Toby's an unhappy guy and he's not going
to be happy because he's just chasing
this ever-growing number which is
definitely not you're chasing and I can
say that for sure but is there an aspect
of it that makes it hard for you to
appreciate where you are currently or is
it different I think that is I I did
you're right I mean I I I have an
incredible like I'm the most fortunate
purpose person on the planet I sometimes
think right like I have an incredible
family a free free boys a wonderful
marriage I'm Mona I'm on one of those
journeys I had an incredible scale
surrounded by friends so I have kind of
a lot of things going on going on there
going for me but I mean look III
suddenly have my demons too right like I
am I do like I'm pretty serious but I
I'm going for minimal distance of the
person I'm meeting at the end of a life
until the person I become i I said very
high requirements to me partly because I
know that I was the bottleneck of
shopify for a couple of years around
that sort of 2008 it was nine time
period right it was just I was holding
this back and a lot of my you know
family friends or so I were dependent on
this thing poking out for for obvious
reasons and so I just I I'm I just
really don't want to get in this
position again I need to I need to
challenge myself intrinsically to be
ahead like to understand what comes next
- you know for - for better for worse if
you're running a company and then you're
sort of a product type CEO you
to have a pretty good crystal ball about
the future and where things are going
and it doesn't need to be always right
but it certainly should be more right
than it isn't because you taking
building software takes a while and if
you're building against it now it's
going to be oh it in two years when it's
done right and so you need to build
against the state of a world in two
thousand twenty one to twenty two and so
on so like I'm chasing like becoming the
best version of myself and that has a
lot of good comes from that but it's it
can also be stressful what what do you
think caused you to be the bottle that
could you define what that means to have
been the bottleneck and why do you think
that happened right was it because you
didn't know how to hire you weren't
willing to hire because you for whatever
reason weren't expanding your skillset
fast enough like what did it mean to be
the bottleneck and and looking backwards
how do you do the the forensic analysis
I just did not make decisions that had
to quick enough like it was this whole
thing about should I take like a Shopify
a lifestyle business or a growth company
is this I struggled with this so much it
seems silly now because obviously like
we can all look at the result of it
becoming a growth company at some point
but it was really unclear to me and so I
I very I ran it cash based like looking
at bank accounts and making decisions
based on hey I only I need this amount
of money in my bank before I can put
five hundred dollars and google adwords
and so on and i just made a lot of
decisions way too slow because i just
didn't feel comfortable understanding
the implications of them and and and and
i didn't know i was doing this and i I'm
really unhappy about it but I did and
I'm really unhappy but I did i I think I
intentionally slew magma unintentionally
slowed down the growth of a company for
a period of time so that I could stay on
top of it and once I've only realized
this after I finally made the call to
just say okay let's get some venture
capital and once we had extra money and
quit spend it on all these like
marketing campaigns which we never did
it's like every single one which
I booked and the company just took off
in a dick to a degree that is almost
almost comical like the VCS are still
talking about those times as something
but I've never seen before like I got I
got my Sirius B I think six or seven
months after the Series A and I just
gave it away at the money before we even
started talking about it's like you need
more money like you didn't raise enough
money right because the numbers were so
good and so it's it's I just held it
back and I don't want to do this again
so why do is for people listening
they're gonna wait a second
faris don't gloss over that so
everything worked
why did everything work was it because
you were bootstrapped and I don't you
know I'm not trying to answer the
question for it but it was it because
you're a bootstrapped and therefore all
of the focuses on the product for an
extended period of time was it because
of something else was it because you had
a lot of interaction with your customers
and therefore knew how to position
things then when you turn them into
expensive or more expensive campaigns
you had already honed the material what
were the why did things work yeah a
little bit of all of us have things like
Shopify then it came out 2006 was a
brilliant solution to the problem of I
need to start an online snowboarding
store unless you have happen to also
want to make a snowboarding store it was
no good
and but I was a customer support I'm top
of everything else and you know here's
the kind of interaction that happened
all the time it's like someone would
send me an email saying I cannot imagine
like you were calling yourself an
e-commerce system and you don't even
have this feature and you know I'm on
the other side of this email and I'm
like starting to try to write an essay
about why were wrong and it's clearly
not coming together so this then means I
spend the entire night I implement the
feature I deploy in the morning and I
replied with an email saying actually
what are you talking about is right here
so you know that on top of also having
been a merchant and really understand
like I'm like I was honest LM in
absolute
love this particular problem in the same
degree
McFee so I'm a McLean was in love the
shipping want like shipping things I'm
in love with I for this type of business
this sort of retail product based
business I just want to give people a
chance to build like to reach for
independence and start something that's
meaningful and you become turns him into
an entrepreneur because I remember what
it felt like when I did it and so they
spent years just chipping away of his
problem making it better and better
making Shopify better it really came
together around 2008-2009 and then the
financial crisis kind of just just
happened and before we were dead but
suddenly at this point it was actually
quite good at this point and it was also
really cheap compared to everything else
so people started with the services so I
was right it's not like we have people
converting from like nine hundred
thousand dollars a year bill to a $59
plan a month right like month plan so
which of course tells you exactly as how
good I was at business at this time but
like but for a service was a point of
pride right we love this and so we
really but we've invested everything
into a product like bit there was a
twenty years in our mind roadmap which
we couldn't get to it because it was
tiny team and so so again in this time
for him the software was really good but
then the people who use it loved it but
the it was hard to get the word out and
so but to test anything I always had it
like every time I had five thousand
dollars additional reoccurring a month I
had to make a decision to even going to
hire this one person but it's gonna be
really good for a product or am I going
to spend this as a test for in some kind
of marketing capacity and so what I
ended up doing finally and that was the
right thing to do is I got the top five
ideas for marketing ideas I saved up the
twenty five thousand dollars so I could
you know you know divvy readout but
amongst opposed ideas and said okay
let's try all of them
and like because if one of them really
accelerates our growth then we are
actually a growth company and we should
get venture capital and we should know
sooner rather than later and should have
done it sooner
right no no I'm saying you do all five
but wants to suppose sequentially
because then you get the feedback
exactly yeah exactly because otherwise
we don't know maybe suddenly I mean it's
a it's a reality changed too much
if this wasn't still not very scientific
but it's more it was better to do it at
the same time because there are
different ideas like radio and adverts
in this way and have a campaign in this
way and if I [ __ ] it was stunning
honestly they all worked and they every
single one clocked in better than what
we expected a highly successful campaign
should return at which point I took this
as a Excel spreadsheet to the venture
capitalists and said I here's a formula
I need to fund this formula right and
then I just changed the conversation
putting it there like Toby I remember
when you came around a bike oh my god
formula the the it's you said earlier
you know there's a lot of chance
involved with a lot of this stuff but
you can and I'm I wish I could give
credit to the writer who came up with
this term and I'm blanking you may know
who this is but they talk about a a luck
surface area an increasing your luck
surface area so that chance has a higher
likelihood of sticking you know that's
there's a lot of a lot of confusion in
that sense but the importance of that
hands-on those customer calls
I think Hart over state yeah right and I
know I know some companies that require
all of their executive hires to do a
period of customer support yes yeah same
with you guys yeah well in the front
lines and I still do I take customer
calls I I do periodically I vote with
customer support um at my own account
there I take some tickets and I take the
phone
hello I go visit customers all the time
it's you know this is actually like the
distance to frontline becoming bigger
has probably killed more companies than
me from probably many other forces but
people would immediately think about
than been talking about disruption yeah
I love it to be less just just a few
more questions and and then then we'll
wrap we have we have some dinner maybe
some wine or something else to have to
later but you mentioned the crystal ball
mm-hmm and the importance of looking
into the future particularly with the
types of products you're developing and
the technology that you work with to go
back to my notes here we go John Philips
considers it his job to go in luca's
office once in a while and get him to
clear everything off his desk as CEO he
feels I shouldn't have any actual hurt
to do it will pull kind of gloss over
that part quote he has guys to do that
if he medals in it he'll cause a problem
which I like I was pretty funny but
thinking you have to be looking ahead
how does this is just you would be a
super fantasy of mine is it literally
clearing stuff off your desk what is
what does John or other people do to
help get you out of the stuff you
shouldn't have your hands in yeah I I
mean this has been a such a journey
right like I mean I I'm I I want to say
I I like really high level strategic
things and I like the absolute tiny
minuti telling you and you are also in
the customer tickets and a bride I the
thing that I optimize away is everything
between was to write and so that that
helps a lot because you know again these
tickets matter right I I think John has
been like he has been such a massive
help he's the same person I mentioned
earlier who came to me and said are you
you never told me you never find someone
we're gonna care as much about Shopify
as you do which encouraged me to take
the CEO role so he was they had many
important parts of shop for journey and
I was full of good advice and so you
have me sort of build out this practice
over time to just
the higher good great people for for for
everything in the middle and allow me to
think about the the sort of long-term
big-picture kind of things and but I
really really really do like going and
putting my chair and in some part with
engineers working on some you know
important performance details and so on
but that that teaches me something about
the company and it also it just it
allows me to access this the latent
pieces of mastery that I once built
which is actually you know you were
talking about happiness and contentment
like tapping into some kind of mastery
you just can't you keep you can't spend
all your time just working on things
which are going to finish two three
years up from now it's it's it just
doesn't leave a feedback loops too long
it's it doesn't it doesn't nourish you
in in the way that like just doing
something that's fun yes to do you know
so that's a really important component
but lastly on this crystal ball I mean
here's the way I think about it um I I
find that like so first of all future is
not predictable and like a features a
random walk and depends on macroeconomic
events and then climate change and
million other things so you can't
actually know the future by the two
things you can do one is really
important which is just just just draw
the trend lines forward sort of like
like a minor version of what records for
I would do right just like in 2009 we
knew that almost all traffic to shop if
I would be coming from mobile phones by
just looking at data and connecting two
points and drawing it forward but it was
kind of predictable computers getting
faster you know a our class is getting
mmm being around and all these kind of
things like we should add voice into a
calendar to say by then they probably
are very important and we should be
aware of them so that's one component
the other much more interesting
component is you need to be a credible
witness to reality and you have to have
a model of what this is currently
January 2019 almost no one in the world
knows what January 2019 actually looks
like because of exactly what
think what you just talked about if you
just sorry where it's just not evenly
distributed yet there it used to be that
you could go to certain Valley and what
you would see around you observing the
things around you would be a pretty like
potentially 95% accurate rendition of
the most up-to-date current version of
the particular time you win so if you
were an entrepreneur in Silicon Valley
and you looked around gives you and user
said okay I'm I'm I'm seeing what you
boarded with letting cars just appear by
pushing a button on my magical piece of
glass in my pocket I'm gonna do I'm
gonna try to disrupt the laundry
industry I'm gonna do it in that way
right you just by osmosis kind of aware
of what's possible now it's much harder
China is a much better component for
instance like a lot of innovations
coming from China and and a lot of
people have not realized that China is
completely flipped on its head in terms
of it's not just copying ideas from the
West it's actually delivering ideas like
these fully automated supermarkets that
people are talking about and coming to
various cities all over China yeah the
way they use facial recognition the game
of fire citizen behavior in certain
cities and WeChat yeah features built-in
it's yeah yeah I don't wanna I want to
stay away from sort of a moral and
political side of China but like I think
just looking at it for just what is life
like in China it's appreciatively more
futuristic than it is anywhere else by
just if they are in a post credit card
world through which I pay and all these
kind of things may they FF it unlocks
completely new business models for them
and so it's it's very understanding but
there's other things like who actually
in the business world understands the
video game industry
it's the biggest industry no one cares
about right it's like so yeah I were one
time no I don't wanna interrupt but I
will since I've barely had too much
caffeine which is I remember one point I
know nothing about very little about
videos but I remember I was looking at
because you see it all the time if you
go to say Rotten Tomatoes you see the
the box office earnings of the biggest
movies in the world
at least domestically and then I saw
some of the the numbers for video game
releases and it just it was a multiple
of the entire total of the list yeah
yeah the video game industry is a good
deal larger than television music and
how I would combine incredible right but
it's also one of the most competitive
environments ever like it's it's a it's
it essentially is a massive industry on
the Hollywood model that a hit is
everything that everyone names am set
one hit like clears the money from the
industry and so what these guys have
found out in the video game industry
about just team cyclist is fascinating
and hugely futuristic compared to what
we sort of businesspeople figured out
and so you see so what I'm getting at is
you do a trend line thing and I think
that's table stakes and people just need
to do a good job of doing that but
that's also not that hard
and then you have to look around the
planet and and just say where is
competitive fields what wills have they
figured I have the winners figured out
in them how can I import boss back into
the rest of the world and I think
through the intersection of those two
disciplines you can actually get a
crystal ball and make assumptions on the
future that start becoming reasonably
precise so that they are better than not
having them as a guiding force for for
making product decisions and so on Toby
the Oracle of Ottawa I'm so wrong you
know way you shouldn't have just said
that because now I'm gonna make it my
job so let's wrap up with a couple of
questions that I like to ask and
listeners seem to enjoy I'll just go for
some of the hard ones if you had a
billboard metaphorically speaking to get
a message or quote a question a word he
scratches lifted his glasses and
scratching his eyes as I'm asking this
so that's that's it's it's a sign you
ask his question
that's a sign of approval what might you
put on it can't be an advertisement I
mean I'm gonna stay on topic
entrepreneurship is precious and needs
to be celebrated this is what I would
put on the billboard on the billboard
besides the books that you've mentioned
are there any other books that you would
put that that is one that comes to mind
is most frequently gifted or recommended
it doesn't have to be one book could be
whatever comes to my mind the most
frequently gifted focus of elements of
style because I just just I like good
writing of aggressive thing to employees
but like a lot of I think I might have
50 copies in my office John by the way
great use on the semicolon however
here's a gift yeah it's more like hey I
like the content of the memo but like I
don't think you've written an on passive
sentence and I think we need to talk so
stereotypes like most German thing I've
ever
yeah we have to talk about your passive
voice now I mean I I love giving to
people at the exact like I try to of
course aim at at the right moment is a
guy to quit life is one of the best
books I've ever read
that's the introduction to start oh
cecilia Mervin yeah exactly yeah I think
that's a that's a best gateway to walk
into this world I seen it was a great
book I read them absolutely did you read
um the courage to be disliked no but I
love the title it's a probably the best
book I've ever had in the last couple
years Wow
it's an introduction to Adlerian
psychology which is felt like it was
sort of anti Freud they were sort of the
two of two factions in the Vienna what
was the name it's called the courage to
be disliked but the these psychologists
I think Alfred Adler okay name and
absolutely fantastic I mean clearly a
student of
stoicism but I think he he took it
further his concept of the separation of
tasks is probably maybe that would be
other thing I would put on a billboard
like yeah but it's hard to put on oh I
think I think it requires a little bit
of context and explanation so what is
the separation of tasks it's just the
basic idea of it's not your task to be
liked it's your task to be likeable and
someone else's tasks to like you or not
it's up to them right just the biggest
wedge between Europe psychology and
someone else's I could ever be driven
into it and and I think potentially a
more tangible way of getting people into
this mindset and I think the Stoics who
came at it through a very sort of high
mindedness right like maybe it all makes
sense but it doesn't like I think what
outlet is really well as he developed
tangible tools for to facilitate a lot
of us kind of outcomes but first or ever
Stoics / sort of reasoning about so a
fascinating book courage to be disliked
that is that is one of the better titles
I've heard in a very very long time
agreed do you have any parting requests
asks for the audience last comments that
for now you would like to like to make
anything you'd like to ask them to do
suggest that they might check out or any
anything at all you'd like to say yeah
big broad question I mean like again
like we didn't really get into visitors
too much I sort of alluded to it at
probably enough oh like I'm a huge fan
of people just going for it
reaching for independence being like
building businesses I think it's it's
worthwhile for especially your
listenership to sort of understand that
there's no force in a law of the
universe that makes entrepreneurship
stick around it's actually happens
because governments and like various
people make very deliberate choices to
to facilitate it reducing friction
massively increases for participation in
entrepreneurship this is this is not a
plaque of Shopify shop
is a player in the space but actually we
need more companies to figure out ways
to reduce the friction of
entrepreneurship across venta entire
spectrum of how people engage in
entrepreneurship because I think if you
don't this is gonna end up being a
serious economical issue eventually
because by the time people figure out
like why is employment going away well a
small business employment is don't oh
it's actually because there's small
businesses are going down there's
potentially so many systemic effects in
play that it's gonna be hard to undo a
lot of damage and so I think it's an
underappreciated area of
entrepreneurship it is entirely possible
to build a company that's highly
valuable by focusing on this you don't
have to go up market like a way everyone
tells you to especially specifically
investor types and then chop if I proves
out of way if you're looking for for a
kind of blueprint and so I would love
for more people to think about this when
you're going into your oracle tool kit
with the crystal ball and surveying the
global landscape are there any
particular countries or cities that you
think are worth examining or modeling
that do a good job I don't know if
Singapore would be an example yeah but
it's sort of Singapore but it's also
like Stockholm is never one so which
what's going on in Berlin is really
interesting but the good but also Jen
Jen Jen Jen it's it
I think visiting Jen Jen would be highly
highly and that's SH en zhe inch engine
@h yeah yeah I think so Jen Jen this is
exactly the kind of thing I have trouble
with dyslexia but is this pretty hard
for everyone but it's you know just
because you go in like the world's
biggest electronic markets and you
realize hey if I wake up early enough
and make my goal - I'm gonna build my
own cell phone I can be done by the end
of a day by just getting components in
this place right and these buildings
just don't exist anywhere else in the
world and that kind of everything is
possible
attitude is also shared by everyone
there
it's a it's an it it's a it's a really
fascinating place it's really
interesting so I think that's uh
absolutely ice what you figured it out
yeah that's I mean that has sort of a a
silver lining on what could be a very
large systemic problem is that there are
exemplars out there I mean there are
cases to study Toby this is so fun I'm
really glad that we ended up having the
opportunity to cross paths yet again and
sit down
of course people can find out more about
Shopify Shopify calm on Twitter they can
say hello to you at Toby TOB I and then
Twitter Instagram LinkedIn of course
shop files on all these platforms and
I'll link to everything in the show
notes I also have a reddit link here and
maybe you can explain what that is there
[Music]
that is is not to be mentioned the name
that shall not be spoken
and I'll link to everything we discussed
the books and so on the principles
philosophers psychologists in the show
notes at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast as per usual you can just search
Shopify or Toby tio bi and everything
will pop right up
Toby thank you so much it says upon Y a
really good time but I've always enjoyed
spending time with you I you for me and
if you've you started off very humble
and understated you remain very humble
and understated which i think is a real
testament to to you and I think it is
true the companies tend to develop a
culture around the personality and
attributes of their leaders and you've
just you've assembled a fantastic team
and built a wonderful company that's
doing a lot of good thank you so much
Tim and again that kudos to you to
actually thank you to you too you were a
big inspiration along the way you
massive help thanks for making yourself
available then they needed you and it
was incredibly gratifying
to spend you know that really fun day at
a New York Stock Exchange ring about
being there together so it's it's again
it's all about being on a journey
surrounded by friends so thank you so
much to being a friend of a company yeah
my pleasure and it went honor to have
been in the right place at the right
time rails company and it is it is it is
really important to have companions on
the path so many adventures ahead and to
everybody listening thank you for tuning
in and try to figure out which box
you're in and check out some of the
resources in the show notes thanks for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun for
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek comm
all spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while wordpress lead developer CEO of
automatic matt mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NBA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurtle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get ala carte style so
visit legalzoom.com and check out their
business section for all their services
and if you want special savings that's
the terminology and the copy that they
suggest I don't know what the special
savings is folks but its titillating if
you want special savings enter promo
code Tim T I am at checkout capital T
lower case I am again take peak
legalzoom.com and enter promo code Tim
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using probably
for about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you'd like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep
motivated there are also up to fourteen
new classes added every day with more
than 8,000 classes on-demand and you can
pick based on length 45 minutes 20
minutes whatever music hip hop rock and
roll or say low impact versus high
intensity or interval you can pick the
class structure and style that works for
you and in my case I quite like Matt
Wilford and I tend to do on-demand and
listen to a lot of and watch many of the
same classes over and over but I'm kind
of promiscuous and also enjoy classes
from a lot of the other instructors they
have peloton an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and
personalities so you can find what
you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyze you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way and Santa vies
me but they really 100% hit the nail on
the head I was very very impressed with
how motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings a studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
comm that's o and e peloton PE l OT o
and.com and enter the code Tim all caps
at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your policy one bike
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started
you
[Applause]